[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
or going back and forth like oh [ __ ]
like what's gonna happen with dogecoin
after snl
all this speculation so if anyone
doesn't know dogecoin is basically this
crypto
that's based on like a meme so basically
after like bitcoin ethereum and all
these other cryptos popped up in 2013
this kid made this like crypto that was
basically just like
a fake using old bitcoin technology
there's no market cap on it which means
you can keep on mining it there's like
billions of the coins
there's still blockchain the whole deal
yeah but it's just based off this little
shiba inu like dog that was a meme back
in the day that they called doge so now
it's dogecoin
so basically it started popping up and
you could buy it for like you know
they're trading at like one cent a coin
or whatever
i'm sorry what just happened my girl
needs to start messaging me before she
buys [ __ ] because
speaking of dogecoin
lulu in georgia what's that oh that's a
furniture store
[Laughter]
so i looked at the ship from here and i
my vision is going but i saw a comma
from here and i was like
this chick done lost her goddamn mind
buying [ __ ] with a comma without telling
me yeah
that's andrew coin brother that's
schultz coin bro to the moon
if there's a comma you got to call me
yeah yeah call me for the comma
she's a day trader bro but it's
furniture so a comma is to be expected
and i'm sure she ran this by you
hey but you just weren't ready she
definitely ran a buyer you were like
buy so many things they sent me a
powerpoint with like 15 things on it and
i just agree on the powerpoint yeah baby
we have so many things to do and then
they sneak in the expenses
turns into running and buying yeah yeah
yeah
fun i literally that was shocking to me
right there dude
by the way does it hurt knowing that i
have a discount to that store that you
didn't ask me
now what is that what was that right
there when you like had an advantage but
you didn't share with anybody
i didn't have it i just wanted to get
you sweaty but it's a it's a it's a good
brand
it stuff's fire no he does that that's
fine what's it called you do want a room
i don't want to shout them out again
okay okay oh my god
that's me and i'm gonna shout them out
for a hundred dollars
before you do the comma purchases please
that should be baseline if there's a
comment to purchase you have to text me
why are you getting updates but you
don't need this in your life i need
updates it might be giving you money you
all got my [ __ ] index i need [ __ ]
updates
no that's my point you don't need people
with miamix you don't need updates
[ __ ]
from wtf media probably still got my
addict
i just give them a [ __ ] out to everybody
everybody who's ever
been a part of my business has my
[ __ ] hammock just going is up baby
my business manager messaged me the
other day and they're like yo someone
just returned something worth five
thousand dollars and they're like
do you know what rhp is or some [ __ ] and
i was like fam
shut up and keep it all right so should
we talk about another topic no how's
al's doge debacle
oh my god i'm sorry for beginning
interrupting that you didn't
go you didn't interrupt i didn't
interrupt no
okay you were trying to save your bank
oh that's true that's true i was
interrupted yeah
okay so so i first of all this was so
sweet because i did not know
anything was going on with this and i
just saw mark laughing hysterically yeah
oh it made me so happy oh my god okay
mark has been trying to get me to get
dogecoin for months yeah i was trying to
yeah
if you put in the amount of money you
put in bitcoin or dogecoin how much
money would you like
how much less how was it possible less
less
at some point less at some point less
what does that mean
at some point
sorry everybody i took investing advice
from
pushing through that moment of
awkwardness there were seven different
conversations going on
but we finally have gotten back to our
focus point
okay mark tell the story about how lost
all his money yeah
we're in the green room okay and we're
all talking about dogecoin we're like
dude elon's gonna talk about dogecoin
and the monologue and the sketch it's
gonna spike it's gonna go super high
it's gonna hit a dollar by sunday yeah
and then it's gonna crash by tuesday so
let's all buy in now
it's gonna go big and then we sell on
tuesday and then we'll all make a ton of
money
and uh that was miles this whole
strategy miles is sort of our like miles
is
maybe the worst investor in the history
of investors i think he is the worst
investor he really is because
he talks about investments he lost this
[ __ ] has gone all in on dogecoin
he had bitcoin and sold it dumb early
yeah he did dude that's no he did that
with bitcoin and dogecoin he bought it
like half a cent and then sold it at six
cents and then that was it he's like
yeah bro
i made my money made money all right so
go on so boom what happened so elon goes
on so apple's got all his money so
i'll go i'm putting in five grand okay
puts up five g's throws into dogecoin
and now what a five
hour before why are you trying to front
on the podcast i'm going to let that go
i didn't know how much it was so he put
in a grand in dogecoin but it's still a
lot of money
and then he puts it up and then as soon
as he goes on stage
second he goes up that [ __ ] drops
immediately
trump falls like what 30 points and i
hit a vowel and he doesn't even know yet
so i just keep on watching it and i
don't tell him and i just keep on
watching the fall and it keeps on going
i saw mark's story with the dogecoin
prizes said this is so funny and i
didn't know why
oh laughing hysterically in my face but
apparently elon had a [ __ ] sketch
where he called it a hustle
[ __ ] idiot yeah you guys are hustling
he's not an idiot you got hustle bro
yeah the biggest person the biggest
proponent of it don't call it a hustle
yeah because we all know it's a hustle
yeah but as long as he doesn't have
midfield money on the hustle
as long as he doesn't admit that you're
just trying to make money while it's a
meme
we know this but there's no no no
dummies like miles
but miles thought it was going to the
moon baby
so you put in the grass this [ __ ]
bought something
is that real guy look at the phone
please verify
that it's real sometimes the answer is
cassie
oh my goodness i'm just joking she
didn't buy a thing i just had to get us
out of that moment
[Laughter]
oh my god okay so al how much did you
lose total
i didn't lose anything oh my god stop
but you mean you didn't lose anything
because i bought in
early when it was low so my initial
investment it kind of like canceled out
so it's like bro you bought in the hour
before the yeah you bought it under the
stocks i had already
had if you count the money that you
spent before how much you lose from the
thousand
oh from down like 200 it's not bad okay
this what i felt was the most
interesting thing with the the whole
dogecoin fiasco is um
it's in a weird way the proof of
slippery slope
but from the side of the people not from
the side of like the oppressive
tyrannical government yes so i go to al
yo you're just gonna sell it you might
as well just sell it
and then al goes i've been trying to go
on robin hood and they won't let me i
can't access my account or you just
wouldn't let yourself they wouldn't let
you sell right
now a few weeks ago when robin hood did
that with gamestop
we flipped out we're like yo the fbi i
gotta arrest this [ __ ] this is
an absolute
crime like how can this person not be in
jail right now it's disgusting what
they're doing they're rigging the
markets etc
right people like i'm boycotting robin
hood i'll never put my money with robin
hood this is [ __ ] up and [ __ ] up
what they're doing right
three weeks later when it happens al is
just like yeah it's annoying but it is
what it is
so the slippery slope is not often the
government
it's the people allowing themselves to
be oppressed
yeah so it's the government or the
people in power are always going to try
to you know utilize that power to get
what they want
right but the people's tolerance
is what adjusts and we've just become
comfortable with the fact that if robin
hood or these other accounts just
don't want to let us sell our [ __ ]
because it could benefit them
they might and we just got to sit there
and take it that's kind of wild
oh i actually thought it was an issue
with the structure like too many people
trying to sell it once yeah that was
because it started [ __ ] figure
your [ __ ] out
what is this too many people trying to
sell them once your whole app is sell
buy and sell like you have two things to
worry about yeah
but i think buy and sell now the whole
thing is you could do it right now
i think what it says to me is the the
[ __ ] he's extra solid but he's like
some people can buy all the time you
know i mean they buy super easily
so they're buying everyone's selling you
know it's like
when everybody tries to buy jordans at
once and the [ __ ] app the website
just crashes
it's just only so many transactions a
website make a better website bro
i ain't got time for this i know we're
not you've got my money amanda's trying
to get your money out the bank and the
bank is like yo we're just too many
people trying to get money at the back
yeah yeah suck my dick
yeah you making money off my money and
then when i need to make some money
you're not gonna let me
[ __ ] you yeah that's crazy because you
only had
a thousand in there imagine you put a
million in there
now imagine you had a million in robin
hood and you're like i gotta sell
this [ __ ] is going down it wasn't going
the way that i thought it was gonna go
this is my kids college fun et cetera
yeah now all of a sudden it's not oh the
website's down
yeah it's like yo you were stealing my
money yeah
that's crazy now with the gamestop thing
in the crypto thing it's a little
different just because like there's a
precedent for
gamestop where it's like with the with
stock trading like there's a
i guess a history of how stock trading
goes whereas like with crypto it seems
like it's just kind of wild
wild west baby that's what crypto
[Applause]
cowboys
you